tras días de un viaje agotador es un
difícil de regreso a casa para muchos
zursulaneses alcanzaron la ciudad de
Rincón solo unas pocas maletas pero los
refugiados llegan más rápido de lo que
pueden ser trasladados a nuevos lugares
aumentando el riesgo de enfrentamientos
entre comunidades huimos de la guerra y
vinimos aquí volvió a ver violencia no
entendemos lo que está pasando tenemos
hambre y sed y está lloviendo y no
tenemos láminas de plástico estamos
cansados y no sabemos cómo se resolverán
nuestros problemas
muchos en Sudán del sur temen lo que
podría ocurrir si continúan los combates
en el país vecino ya que hace más de un
mes que empezó la guerra en harton una
preocupación compartida por el director
general del programa mundial de
alimentos de la uni incluso antes de
esta crisis el 70% de la población
necesitaba ayuda humanitaria Y en este
momento el programa mundial de alimentos
no puede cubrir sus necesidades vamos a
tener dificultades para cubrir cualquier
de las necesidades en este momento
de Sudán en 2011 y se hundió en una
guerra civil hace sólo cinco años que se
firmó un acuerdo de paz después de años
de enfrentamientos entre el gobierno y
las fuerzas de la oposición del lado de
Sudán los combates entre el ejército y
una milicia rival mataron al menos a 863
civiles antes de que comenzara un alto
el fuego de siete días la semana pasada